voters in Turkey head to the polls
tomorrow for a referendum that threatens
to bolster the power of the country's
democratically elected president after
14 years of leading the NATO ally and
u.s. partner in combating Isis President
Recep Tayyip erawan is asking for rights
that some argue could make him more of a
dictator Holly Williams has more from
Istanbul this is no ordinary vote it's a
turning point
well Hamas resident Reggie opieop
everyone tells his adoring base many of
them poor religious conservatives from
the country's hinterland he's
campaigning to weaken turkeys ports and
lawmakers giving himself sweeping new
powers he's like an angel
mityay humours todas will vote yes with
our whole heart Turkey is America's NATO
ally a partner in the fight against Isis
and for many years the u.s. held Turkey
up here in the Middle East as a model of
democracy and stability but now
president earlier ones critics say this
referendum could smooth the path for him
to become a dictator there's a new
climate of fear here in Turkey which
began nine months ago when an attempted
military coup came close to asking
President Erdogan for power in response
a mass purge of anyone who wants
government views as an enemy around
50,000 have been arrested including more
than 2,000 judges and prosecutors as
well as journalists university
professors doctors a concert pianist and
an American pastor who's lived here for
more than 20 years
Barbara's shunt so is a fashion designer
who just spent two months in prison for
posting comments online that offended
the government one iron Barrett one
blanket three steps or three steps caged
air alone totally alone he was beaten by
a pro-government mob in January and is
so worried it'll happen again he rarely
leaves his
that's a pretty frightening thought in
what is supposed to be a democracy
democracy I bet you thought are you
saying Turkish democracy is finished
almost in ruins new 1000 room
presidential palace he's surrounded by
the trappings of Turkey's imperial past
some here fear his real ambition is to
become a modern-day Sultan for life for
CBS this morning Saturday Holly Williams
Istanbul